COMMITTEE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE ASSEMBLY IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING IS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS IT IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. EVERYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OF PROPERTY WERE
MASK AT ALL TIMES. THIS
INCLUDES ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO PROVIDES PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE. PUBLIC COMMENT
THEY CAN BE PROVIDED BY PHONE
OR HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND ON THAT LINE
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
AND IF ANYONE WERE TO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
RULES COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2800
AGAIN 916-319-2800 AND MY STAFF
WILL SEEK TO ASSIST. COMMENTS
CAN ALSO BE SUBMITTED VIA
EMAIL. TO THE JOINT DOT RULES.
PARDEE JOINT TO DOT RULES ACTS
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV JOINT DOCKED
RULES AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV.
LAST YEAR HEARING TODAY WILL
HAVE A HARD STOP AT TWELVE
THIRTY IN ORDERS FOR THE
CHAMBER CAN BE CLEANED PURSUANT
TO COVERT PROTOCOLS PRIOR TO
OUR FOR SESSION AT ONE PM TODAY.
AS BACKGROUND ON TODAY'S JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE MEETING TODAY
IS THE SEVENTH JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING CONVENED
AROUND THE TOP OF THE
CAPITALIZE PROJECT. IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. THE INAUGURAL
MEETING WAS HELD ON JULY SIXTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. INFORMATION
ON THIS PROJECT BEEN READ UP.
AND CONTINUOUS AVAILABLE ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S ANNEX PROJECT
WEBSITE. WHICH IS W. W. W. DOT
ATTICS DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV IN HIS BILL ON THAT WEBSITE
SINCE APRIL OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOUR YEARS AGO. THE ANNEX
PROJECT WELL IT HAS ITS ROOTS
IN A SESSION SO THE BUILDING
CONDUCTED DURING THE
SCHWARZENEGGER ADMINISTRATION.
WAS REALLY PUT IN MOTION IN
JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN'S BUDGET MESSAGE
ANNOUNCED HIS PLAN TO FUND THE
COST OF REBUILDING THE CAPITOL
ANNEX. THAT'S YEAR GOVERNOR FOR
THAT PLEDGE SO INTO LAW CHAPTER
THIRTY ONE OF THE STATUTES OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN. THAT LAWN ISSUE
THE FUNDING AND ASSIGNED TO
THIS COMMITTEE THEN LED BY
CHAIR RICH GORDON. RESPONSIBLE
PURSUE THE REPLACEMENT OR
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE KAPLAN OF
BUILDING. TO ADDRESS ITS MANY
AGE RELATED DEFICIENCIES. TOP
PRIORITIES INCLUDE DOING A
BETTER JOB VIRGIN PUBLIC SAFETY
ELEMENTS IN THE BUILDING'S
DESIGN AND LAYOUT. AND MATURELY
UPGRADING ADA ACCESS CAPITALIZE.
IN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS COMMITTEE INITIATED PLAN
STUDY COMPLETED IN DECEMBER OF
THAT YEAR WHICH DOCUMENTED THE
KNOWN LIFE SAFETY HAZARDS OF
THE CURRENT ANNEX. THAT STUDY
NOTED THAT THE RISK FOR
BUILDING OCCUPANTS AND VISITORS
IN A FIRE OR AFTER AN
EARTHQUAKE. OR INCREASED BY
OVERCROWDING AND CONFUSED A
DIFFICULT EXITING FROM THE
PARMELEE CONGESTION UPPER
FLOORS WHICH LACKS SPRINKLERS.
AGAINST THIS BACKDROP THE CAP
LAST PROJECT TO SUMMARIZE. FULL
CAPITAL FORCE ALMOST TWO
MILLION YEARLY VISITORS.
CONCERT IN NYC RESPONSIBLY
ASSIGNED BY LAW THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LAW STATES THAT RELEVANT
ENTITIES SHALL COOPERATE IN
GOOD FAITH TO EXPLORE AND ADOPT
ANY AVAILABLE AND APPROPRIATE
APPROACHES TO THE WORK. THE
NEXT LIKE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
APPLE PROJECTS AND EFFICIENT
MANNER. TO ALLOW THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE TO HAVE THE
PREEMINENT ROLE IN MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THE DESIGN AND
MANAGE OF THE PROJECT. SO THAT
THEY ADVANCE THE INTERESTS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN EXACTLY
BRANCH IN SERVING CALIFORNIA
FOR DECADES TO COME- THIS
PREEMINENT JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE AUTHORITY ALIGNS WITH
THE STATE CAPITOL'S HISTORY
SINCE THE END OF WORLD WAR TWO.
IN CALIFORNIA A COUPLE BILL IS
UNIQUE IN THE STATE'S BUILDING
OF A TORY BECAUSE BY LAW. FOR
THE LAST SEVENTY YEARS PROJECT
TO UPDATE OR REBUILD THE
CAPITAL. LIKE THE HISTORIC WEST
WING RESTORATION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY TWO.
INDIVIDUAL CAPITALIZE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN FIFTIES HAVE
BEEN DIRECTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO INVITE MY COLLEAGUE-
CENTER HERTZBERG IF HE HAS AN
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS BEFORE
WE- TURN IT OVER TO MR HART AND
MOCHA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I JUST WOULD LIKE TO.
ADOPT YOUR COMMENTS AND JOIN
WITH YOU I WANT TO TAKE THE
TIME. SINCE WE'RE LIMITED ON
OUR SCHEDULE HERE TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND TO. REFER TO
MISTER HART THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GOOD OF. SO I TURN NOW TO.
THE HEART. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING- WE- ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH TODAY AND TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE ATTRIBUTES TO
THE- NEW ANNEX BUILDING WE PLAN
ON COVERING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TOPICS AND AS WE GET
STARTED. I THINK IT'S- LET ME.
SAY THIS THE- CALIFORNIA'S NEW
CAPITAL AND IT SHOULD CONVEY TO
VISITORS CALIFORNIA'S POSITIVE
HOPEFUL OUTLOOK. FOUNDED UPON
THE DELIVERY OF DEMOCRATS-
DEMOCRACY WHICH UNFOLDS THERE
BY WELCOMING ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ENGAGING ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
SAFEGUARDING THE FUTURE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND- DEMONSTRATING
HELPFUL HELPFUL ACCESSIBLE AND
SUSTAINABLE DESIGNS. WHILE
PRESERVING THE BEAUTY INVESTORS
OF CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY CAPITAL
PARK. AND INVITING IT ALL ITS
GUESTS TO EXPLORE AND TAKE
PRIDE IN ONE OF THE MOST ENERGY
EFFICIENT. CAPITOL BUILDINGS IN
THE NATION. I THINK THAT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT QUOTE THAT
OUTLINES AND- KIND OF
SUMMARIZES THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING. OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS SINCE WE'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S WELCOMING AND
ENGAGING AND THAT IT'S OPEN AND
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE RESPECTFUL OF THIS LAND AND
THE HERITAGE OF THIS LAND. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE THAT IS BEAUTIFUL
AND THAT WE PRESERVE THE TREES
IN THE VISTAS AND THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN TAKE PRIDE IN
THIS BUILDING. AS WE MOVE.
FORWARD WE ARE GOING TO TALK
TODAY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SITE DESIGN PRINCIPLES. WE WILL
BE TALKING ABOUT THE TREES AND
THE PARK AND HOW WE HAVE WORKED
WITH THE DESIGN OF THIS
BUILDING TO TRY TO PRESERVE.
ALL OF THE TREES AND TO.
ADDRESS THE- OF THE ASPECTS OF
THE PARK. WE WILL ALSO GO
THROUGH AND LOOK AT THE CAPITOL
IN TOTAL WE WILL LOOK AT THE
PLANS IN THE STACKING DIAGRAMS.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SPACE IN THE LIGHT COURT. AND
FINALLY WE WILL CONCLUDE WITH
THE FACADE DESIGN. SO IS AN
OVERVIEW- THE CAPITOL ANNEX. IS
BEING DESIGNED TO ADDRESS MANY
OF THE ISSUES THAT- THE CURRENT
ANNEXES STRUGGLING WITH ADA
ACCESS AND COMPLIANCE IN
CIRCULATION IN THE CURRENT
ANNEXES- BOTH INADEQUATE AND
DEFICIENT. HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
ABOUND THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING
AND WE HAVE JUST COMPLETED AN
ANALYSIS AND SURVEY AND WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THOSE MATERIALS AND
WILL BE REMOVING THEM-
INADEQUATE BUILDING SYSTEMS ARE
CURRENTLY WITHIN THE- CURRENT
BUILDING AND AN OUTDATED
SEISMIC DESIGN. THE NEW
BUILDING WILL HAVE AN UPDATED
DESIGN THAT WILL ALLOW FOR THE-
TYPE OF SEISMICITY THAT ARE IS
NECESSARY. IN ADEQUATE OFFICE
SPACE WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE OFFICE
SPACE IN THE DESIGN OF THAT
SPACE IS BOTH EFFICIENT. AND
SAFE. CURRENTLY THE FLOORS ARE
NOT ALIGNED WITH THE WEST WING
AND THAT CREATES A NUMBER OF
ISSUES- BOTH EIGHTY A. AS WELL
THE CIRCULATION AS WELL AS
COMMUNICATION AND BEING ABLE TO
DIRECT PEOPLE. AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHERE TO GO AND HOW
TO MOVE THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING
SO WAY FINDING HIS DIFFICULT
CURRENTLY. FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
CONCERNS ARE PROBABLY AMONGST
THE GREATEST THERE ARE
INADEQUATE EXITS THAT CURRENTLY
FILLED THE HALLS OF THE ANNEX.
AS WELL AS THE STAIRWAYS. AND
THEN SECURITY AND THE BUILDING
HAS OUT LIVE THE- BUILDING
CODES WAS BUILT TO. SO YOU THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF A NEW ANNEX
BUILDING. THERE IS A LOT OF
THINGS TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN DESIGNING AN
ANNEX BUILDING BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF BALANCE THAT HAS TO BE
ACHIEVED BOTH WITH REGARDS TO
HOW YOU TREAT THE LAND. HOW YOU
TREAT THE SURROUNDING TREES HOW
YOU TREAT THE BUILDING. AND HOW
YOU DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S SAFE AND SECURE. WE
DEVELOPED THREE DIFFERENT
DESIGNS THERE WAS A DOUBLE T.
DESIGN A CIRCLE DESIGN IN THE
SQUARE DESIGN. WE STUDY THE
ATTRIBUTES AND THE BENEFITS IN
THE DETRIMENTS OF EACH AND THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE. MET SINCE
SEPTEMBER AND IDENTIFIED THE
DOUBLE T. AS THE SCHEME THAT WE
WERE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH. IT IS A FUNCTIONAL
DESIGN. IT IS ALSO A DESIGN
THAT CAN BE BUILT FOR THE
BUDGET. AND IT IS APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET- YOU CAN SEE HERE
THE HOW IT NESTLES IN IT IS
DESIGNED SO THAT IT WORKS WITH
BOTH THE TREES IN THE PARK. IT
ALSO REFLECTS AND DESIRE AT THE
DESIGN OF THE BUILDINGS
DOWNTOWN IT IS NOT I'M OVERLY
MASSIVE BUILDING. IT IS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE ITSELF IN
THE SITE SO THAT IT. IT SETS
SUBTLY BEHIND THE WEST WING OR
THE HISTORIC CAPITAL AND DOES
NOT OVER POWER THE BUILDING AND
WE THINK THESE ARE VERY STRONG
ATTRIBUTES OF THIS DESIGN. WE
WILL NOW TURN THE TIME OVER TO
JOSE PALACIOS WHO IS THE-
DESIGN- PRINCIPAL AND PARTNER
FOR SO M. WHO IS DESIGNING THE
BUILDING. THANK. THANK YOU
DAVID BLOOM- ALL BEGIN SINCE
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE LATE.
WITH THE ALL IMPORTANT DESIGN
PRINCIPLES AND THOSE- DAVID
MENTIONED WE ARE INSPIRED BY
THE STATEMENT THAT HE HAD A
RIGHT AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PRESENTATION. OUR FIRST OUR
FIRST PRINCIPLE IS TO PER SE-
PRESERVE THE BEAUTY OF THE
PARK. AS YOU KNOW THE FOOTPRINT
OF THIS BUILDING IS SURROUNDED.
BY A MANY IMPORTANT TREES- THAT
ARE EITHER VERY LARGE HISTORIC
OR DEDICATED. OUR TEAM HAS BEEN
COMMITTED. TO PRESERVE THE PARK
AS WELL AS PRESERVE A GREAT
NUMBER OF THESE TREES WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT BUT IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NEW PART AT NEW
BUILDINGS ARE. AND THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE- DAVID WALKER FROM P.
W. P. R. LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT
WILL ADDRESS THE DESIGN OF THE
PARK AND- THE SECTION FOLLOWING
THE SECTION IN THE PRESENTATION.
ANOTHER PRINCIPLE IS TO
RECOGNIZE THE PARK IN THE
STYLISH OTHER CONNECTIONS AS
WELL. WITH THIS PROJECT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RELOCATE THE
VEHICULAR PART OF PART RAMPS
THAT- THAT BIFURCATED THE PARK.
N. HAVE THE ABILITY TO GENERATE
CONNECT THE EAST SIDE WITH THE
WEST SIDE OF THE PARK. WE THINK
THAT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BENEFIT OF THIS PROJECT. HERE
YOU SEE THE FOOTPRINT OF THE
BELOW GRADE PARKING EXPANDING
FROM AN L. L. ST TWO AND ST AND
WE HAVE SHAPED. THIS PARKING TO
MISS SOME OF THOSE IMPORTANT
TREES. ON TOP OF THAT PARKING
THE DESIGN PROPOSES THAT A
PEDESTRIAN PROMENADE THAT ALSO
CONNECTS. THE NEW NEED EASTERN
TREE OF THE OF THE CAPITOLINA
X. PROJECT WITH L. N. N. STREET
AND BEYOND WITH THE CITY GRID.
IT ALSO PRESERVES. THE VIEWS TO
THE CAPITOL DOME AS WELL AS
BUSINESS WITHIN THE CAPITOL
PARK. ONE OF THE ONES OF USE
THAT HAS BEEN MOSTLY ENHANCED
ARE THOSE VIEWS FROM THE-
NORTHEAST AND THE SOUTHEAST I
WAS THE PEAK OF THE BUILDING
PULLS AWAY A LITTLE BIT TO
REVEAL MORE OF THE HISTORIC
BUILDING. AND THE DON'T. WITH
THAT I'M GONNA THAT- DAVID
WALKER CONTINUE WITH THAT PART
PERCENT TAKE.
HELLO MY NAME'S
DAVID WALKER AND I'M WITH-
PETER WALKER AND PARTNERS-
WHERE THE LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
WORKING ON THE CAPITAL PROJECT.
AND- C. OKAY- THE HERITAGE AND
MEMORIAL TREES IN THE CAPITOL
PARK ARNIE ARE A VALUABLE-
CULTURAL COLLECTION THAT
PROVIDES A UNIQUELY CALIFORNIAN
CHARACTER OF OUR CAPITOL
GROUNDS THIS COLLECTION OF
TREES AND HISTORIC ARTIFACTS.
HAVE A GREAT SIGNIFICANCE TO
OUR COLLECTIVE CALIFORNIA
HISTORY AND SHOULD CONTINUE TO
BE ADDED TO. WE'VE BEEN
STUDYING THE EXISTING TREES
WITH OUR ARBORIST FOR MORE THAN
A YEAR NOW AND I AM HAPPY TO
REPORT. THAT THE ENTIRE DESIGN
DESIGN TEAM IS COMMITTED TO THE
PRIMARY MANDATE TO DISTURB IS
FEW. OF THE EXISTING TREES AS
POSSIBLE. THE COUPLE PARK IS A
COLLECTION OF TREES THAT
REFLECTS MANY DIFFERENT PERIODS
OF HISTORY. AS THE CAPITAL
FACILITIES HAVE EXPANDED TO
ACCOMMODATE GOVERNMENT NEEDS.
HOWEVER THE CAPITOL PARK TREES
ARE NOT ALL CREATED EQUAL. IN
THIS SLIDE- OF THE EXISTING
SITE YOU CAN SEE THE RELATIVE
SIZE OF THE TREES SURROUNDING
THE HISTORIC WEST WING TO THE
WEST NORTH AND THE SOUTH THERE
THERE THE LARGE. REALLY LARGE-
TREES THAT- CAME ALONG WHEN THE
WEST WING WAS BUILT. BUT YOU
CAN ALSO SEE IN THE PLAN THAT
THE TREES PLANTED DIRECTLY EAST
OF THE EXISTING ANNEX. BETWEEN
THE ANNEX AND TWELFTH STREET.
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER
IN SIZE- THESE ARE THE LARGEST
TREES IN CAPITOL PARK AND THEIR
PLANET AND- WHEN THE WEST WING
WAS BUILT- AT THE TIME OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTY ANNEX
CONSTRUCTION THE AUTOMOBILE
RAMPS CREATED A VERY
DESTRUCTIVE BEAR IN THE CAPITOL
PARK ESSENTIALLY SEPARATING THE
WEST FROM THE EAST. THE
ELIMINATION OF THESE RAMPS WILL
ALLOW THE PARK TO BE CONNECTED
RECONNECTED. TO BE ONE PARK AS
IT WAS ORIGINALLY CONCEIVED.
THIS PLAN SHOWS HOW WE'VE
WORKED CAREFULLY TO INSERT THE
NEW BUILDING PROGRAM
EFFICIENTLY. WITH ONLY WITHIN
THE AREAS THAT INCLUDE THE
REMOVAL OF THE EXISTING RAMP.
AND THE INSERTION OF THE
UNDERGROUND GARAGE ON TWELFTH
STREET. AND ALL WITHIN THE AREA
THAT HAS THE LEAST HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE. WE'RE CURRENTLY
CONSIDERING. AROUND SIXTY TO
SIXTY FIVE CAPITOL PARK TREES
FOR TRANSPLANTING REPLACEMENT
AND PROTECTION IN PLACE WITHIN
THAT AREA THAT SHOWN IN RED.
THIS PLAN SHOWS THE CURRENT
SCHEMATICS SITE DESIGN- THE
LIGHT OLIVE COLORED TREES ARE
ALL THE EXISTING CAPITAL TREES
THAT WILL NOT BE TOUCHED. THE
BRIGHTER GREEN TREE SHOWN ARE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY TO FORTY
TREES EXISTING TREES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED BY THE BUILDING
PROGRAM. AND WILL BE A
TRANSPLANTED TO NEW LOCATIONS.
THE DARK OLIVE COLOR TREES ARE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PROPOSED
TREES- REPLACEMENT TREES GROVES
WHICH WILL FLANK THE PROPOSED
ANNEX AT THIS NORTH AND THE
SOUTH AND LINE THE TWELFTH ST
PROMINENT. AND THEN THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE PALM
TREES AFFECTED BY THE PROPOSED
GARAGE RAMPS ALONG L. AND N.
STREET. WHICH WILL BE MOVED
DIRECTLY IN BOARD ALONG THE
PARK PRINTER WHICH YOU CAN SEE
IN THE PLAN. HIGHLIGHTED IN IN
THE BRIGHTER COLORED TREES
GREEN TREES PALM TREES. THE
MINIMAL INTERVENTION SHOWN IN
THE PLAN WILL CREATE A SEAMLESS
CAPITOL PARK THAT PRESERVES
NEARLY ALL OF THE LARGE
EXISTING TREES. AND ALLOWS
VISITORS TO MOVE MOVE FREELY
EAST AND WEST. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT TO THE CAPITOL
PARK. THAN WHAT EXISTS TODAY.
THANK YOU DAVID AND NOW WILL
MOVE TO PERCENT- THE BUILDINGS
STARTING WITH THE BUILDING
ENTRIES AND PUBLIC SPACE AGAIN
INSPIRED. BY THE SAME-
QUOTATION THAT WE FIND AND- WEB
PORTAL. OR THE CAPITOLINA X.
BUILDING. AT THIS. THE PROJECT
WILL BE WELCOMING ENGAGING
SAFEGUARDING IN THAT IT STARTS
WITH THE ENTRY THERE ARE THREE
NEW ENTRIES ON THE IONIC SIDE.
IN ADDITION TO THE ENTRY. THE
SYMBOLIC ENTRY ON THE WEST
SIDE- OF THE OF THE HISTORIC
BUILDING. THE TWO ENTRIES NORTH
AND SOUTH ARE ALMOST IN THE
EXACT SAME LOCATION AS YOU FIND
THE CURRENT BILLIONS. AND THERE
WILL BE ALSO AN ENHANCED ENTRY
ON THE EAST SIDE OF THE
BUILDING. THIS IS A VIEW OF
THAT ENTRY. THE IDEA IS THAT
THIS WILL BE A- TRANSPARENT.
INVITING WELCOMING AND ALSO
SAVE IN FREE LEAD O- FREE TO
MOVE IN INTO THE BUILDING AS
YOU PROCEED THROUGH THE-
INTERESTED REAL IN THE
SCREENING DEVICES. YOU WILL
WALK INTO A LARGE PUBLIC SPACE
A PUBLIC ROOM OF SORTS. A
SKYLIT OVER OUT ON THE SECOND
FLOOR THAT WILL PERMEATE THE
VIEWS TO THE CAPITAL DAHLE-
VERY STRONG. SYMBOL OF
GOVERNMENT THIS SPACE WILL BE
AMPLE ENOUGH TO MOVE FREELY
CONGREGATE AND PROCEEDING TO-
PARTICIPATING IN TO THE- THE-
HEARING ROOMS. THIS IS THE MOST
PUBLIC FLOOR OF THE BUILDING.
AB ALTHOUGH THIS GUY LIED ON
THE SECOND FLOOR THERE IS A
THERE IS A LIGHT WELL THAT ALSO
WILL PROVIDE DAYLIGHT TO ALL
THE WORK SPACE ABOVE THE SECOND
FLOOR. IN THIS HEALTH FOOD
LIGHT AT DAYLIGHT WILL ALSO
PENETRATE ALL THE WAY TO THE
WHAT WE CALL THE PLAZA LEVEL.
WHERE WE ENTER THE BUILDING
FROM THE EAST SIDE. MOVING ON
TO THE FUNCTIONAL ASPECTS OF
THE BUILDING LIKE DAVIS SAID
THIS BUILDING NEEDS TO BE
FUNCTIONAL EFFICIENT IT NEEDS
TO FACILITATE THE WORK OF
GOVERNMENT. BUT HE ASKED TO DO
SO IN A HELPFUL ACCESSIBLE IS
SUSTAINABLE WAY. HERE'S A VIEW
OF HOW THE PROGRAM STACKS OF
THE BILL. THE PURPLE COLOR THAT
YOU SEE THERE IS LEVEL ONE
WHERE THE EXECUTIVE FLOOR. IS
LOCATED VERY MUCH THE WAY IT IS
TODAY. ALL OF THE FLOORS OF THE
WESTWAY BUT HIS TO BUILDING BY
BE A LOT IN MY LIFE AND
INTEGRATED INTO THE NEW
BUILDING. OF ALL OF THIS A
LEVEL ONE FLOOR THE EXECUTIVE
FLOOR. MOST OF THE LEGISLATIVE.
WORK SPACE BE ACCOMMODATED FROM
LEVELS TWO TO FOUR. BELOW THE
LEVEL ONE THERE'S A PLAZA LEVEL
AND A LOWER LEVEL THE PLASMA
LEVEL IS THE ENTRY LEVEL ON THE
EAST SIDE OF THE BUILDING WHERE
MOST OF THE HEARING ROOMS WILL
BE LOCATED IN THE LOWER LEVEL
IS MOSTLY SUPPORT SPACE AN
ENTRANCE FROM THE PARKING.
HERE'S A VIEW OF THAT EXECUTIVE
LEVEL THAT IS ORGANIZED AROUND
A VERY GENEROUS- CIRCULATION IS
SPACE PUBLIC SPACE IN A U.
SHAPE AND THIS IS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR AND LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR SUITES WILL BE.
LOCATED THE ENTRY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S SUITE IS UP ON THE
SITE. OPPOSITE OF THE ROTUNDA
OF THE WEST WING. AT A BIT
SYMBOLIC OF THE BONDS THE
GOVERNMENT. MOVING ON TO THE
SECOND FLOOR THE ALL IMPORTANT
CONNECTION OF THESE CHAMBERS IN
THE SENATE CHAMBERS. TO THE NEW
BUILDING HAS BEEN TAKEN CARE OF
IN ALL OF THE SUPPORT SPACES OF
THE FACILITATE THE FUNCTIONING
OF THIS CHAMBERS WILL BE
PROVIDED IN THIS NEW BUILDING.
THE REST OF THE FLOOR IS
OCCUPIED BY OFFICE SPACE FOR
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEES. AS WE
MOVE U THERE'S A FLOOR THAT WE
CALL THE LEVEL TWO AND WHICH IS
SANDWICHED BETWEEN LEVEL TWO
AND LEVEL THREE. AS WE HAVE A-
LARGE VOLUME OF THE SPACE- THAT
WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IN
THIS CASE THE MOST OF THE FLOOR
WILL BE OCCUPIED BY THE
ASSEMBLY. THIS IS LEVEL THREE
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THE FLOORS
ARE VERY TYPICAL- WHICH IS
IMPORTANT TO ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCY. AND FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE FUTURE. THE CIRCULATION IS
A CONTINUOUS CIRCULATION THERE
ARE NO DEAD ENDS BUT WE CALL
THE FIGURE EIGHT CIRCULATION.
THAT WILL ALSO. PROMOTE CHANCE
ENCOUNTERS AND FOR THAT REASON
WE'VE ACCOMMODATED THE SPACES
OFF THE CORE THERE. THAT PEOPLE
CAN MEET FOR IMPROMPTU MEETINGS
AND CONVERSATIONS. MOVING ON TO
THE FOURTH LEVEL ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT FEATURES OF THE
FOURTH LEVEL IS THAT WE PLACE
THE CAFE IN THAT LEVEL VERY
MUCH THE WAY THAT IT IS TODAY
ON THE TOP FLOOR. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU CAN SEE THIS
FLOOR. IS THE ABILITY. FOR THE
CONFIGURATION OF THE PLAN. TO
BRING DAYLIGHT TO ALMOST EVERY
SPACE AND EVERYONE WORKING IN
THE BUILDING WHETHER THAT IS
FROM THE PARK. OR THE LIGHT
WELL IN THE CENTER OF THE
BUILDING. MOVING DOWN TO THE
PLAZA LEVEL THIS IS WHERE THE
HEARING ROOM CITED ARE
ACCOMMODATED IN THE ORGANIZED
AROUND A VERY LARGE CENTRAL
SPACE THAT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO
EASILY COME IN AND COME IN AND
GO OUT AS WELL AS A GOOD- LIFE
SAFETY- BENEFIT THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS VERY LARGE ROOMS. WITH A
LOT OF PUBLIC. LASTLY THE FLOOR
BELOW THAT THE LOWER LEVEL IS
MOSTLY USED FOR. SUPPORT SPACES
MAINLY A LOT OF MECHANICAL. AND
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THIS
BILL NEW BUILDING WILL BE A
CLEAN ENERGY WE WILL BE ON ALL
ELECTRIC BUILD. SO ALL OF THE
EQUIPMENT WOULD BE ELECTRIC.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO- A SECURE
ENTRANCE INTO THE BUILDING FROM
THE PARKING. ANOTHER GOOD
SUSTAINABLE POINT TO MAKE IS
THAT WE NEED TO BUILD LESS AND
THE PARKING IS. EQUIPPED WITH A
STACKER PARKING WHICH- REQUIRES
LITTLE OVER HALF THE AMOUNT OF
A STANDARD PARKING SO WE
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF AREA THE
WEEK. KIND OF BUILT ON THE
GROUND. WHAT. THE CEILING
HEIGHT IS UP ABOUT MAYBE
FOURTEEN FEET. SOMEWHERE IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD. SO ARE
MOVING ON TO THE MY THAT
MESSING IN THE FACADE OF THE
BUILDING AGAIN INSPIRED LIKE
THE SAME- THE STATEMENT THAT
YOU FIND IN THE BOOK- WEB
PORTAL. THE NEW DESIGN. IS
RELATE AND RESPECTS THE WEST
WING. THE MASSING OF THE
BUILDING AT IN THE HEIGHT OF
THE MASSING RESPECT THE HEIGHT
OF THE EXISTING BALUSTRADE OF
THE WEST WING. IT ALSO IS
ORGANIZING A THREE BY THREE
PARTITE MANNER WITH THE BASE
MIDDLE AND TOP JUST LIKE THE
WEST WIND IS IN THE
ARTICULATION OF THE FACADE. IS
A VERTICAL AND IN A RHYTHM THAT
IS SIMILAR TO THE COLUMNS IN
THE BY LAST YEAR'S OF THE WEST
WING. WE ARE ALSO EXTENDING THE
EXISTING PLAN. WHERE THE WEST
WING SITS ON TO FURTHER
INTEGRATE. THE NEW BUILDING
INTO THE WEST WING. THIS IS A
TYPICAL VIEW THAT YOU WILL HALF
OF THE BUILDING AT. FROM THE
PART. WHERE THE TREES ARE IN
THE FOREGROUND. WHICH ARE VERY
MUCH PART OF THE OVERALL
COMPOSITION. OF THE DESIGN.
HERE'S A VIEW. OF THE NORTH
COUNTRY WHERE THE BUILDING
RECEIPTS BACK TO CREATE MORE
ROOM FOR THE MOON TREE. AND FOR
THE GROVE OF THE SISTERS OF
MERCY. AND LASTLY HERE'S A VIEW.
FROM THE SOUTHWEST LOOKING AT
THE HISTORIC BUILDING IS STILL
RETAINING HIS PROMINENCE AND
IMPORTANCE AND WITH THE NEW
BUILDING RECEDING IN THE BACK.
WITH THAT THANK YOU AND NOW
WILL- THIS CONCLUDES OUR
PRESENTATION AND HOW WILL
RUSSIA DIRECT FLOOR TO MISTER
GRIFFITH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JOSE FOR THAT PRESENTATION AND-
W. P. AND MISTER HART. SO I
TURNED OUT TO. HOW MY
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROMMEL'S. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION-
AND MONITORING IT AND BEING
INVOLVED IN THIS PROJECT- SINCE
WE GOT TO THE LEGISLATURE- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ON THE TREES AND THAT
TYPE OF A AREA THERE BUT- I
KNOW THERE STILL IS A WORK TO
BE DONE. HOWEVER ONE OF THE
THINGS AND I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT
ON ON ASKING FOR- FOR TRIBAL-
CONSULTATION AND THE INPUT IN
THE PROCESS THAT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN THERE. IS THE QUESTION-
MISTER CHAIRS IS THAT WHAT
PROCESS ARE WE FOLLOWING-
WORKING WITH THE TRIBAL-
GOVERNMENTS HERE IN OUR LOCAL
AREA IS IT SB EIGHTEEN OR AB
FIFTY TWO OR IS OUR DIFFERENT
PROCESSES BEING- ADHERE TO
DURING THIS CONSTRUCTION PHASE.
AT THIS JUNCTURE. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING. PERKASA A TRIBAL
GROUPS FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS BY LAW DGS IS HANDLING
THE SEQUOIA PROCESS WHICH IS
ONGOING. AND- I ANTICIPATE THAT
THEY ARE. APPLYING. GENERALLY
THE PROCESS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CATTO'S AB FIFTY TWO- I AM NOT
PERSONALLY. I'M A NUMBERS GUY
IS A LAWYER BUT EIGHTEEN
DOESN'T STAND OUT TO ME BUT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING
SYSTEMATICALLY WITH. AT THE
REQUEST EARLY ALL WE DID- BUT
CADAVER DOGS TO THE ENTIRE PARK
TO CHECK FOR ANY BURIED HUMAN
REMAINS. WE'VE ALSO DONE OUR
OWN DUE DILIGENCE WITH GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR OF THE SITE
ITSELF. WE HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENT TO USE- SUPPORT
TRIBAL MONITORS WHENEVER ANY
DIGGING IS TAKING PLACE. WITH
PROTOCOL FOR HOW ANY ANYTHING
WHICH IS ENCOUNTERED WILL BE
HANDLED. SO. I SORT OF YOU THIS
IS A TWO PART QUESTION I THINK
BY LAW THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE CONDUCT OF THE SEQUEL
PROCESS FALLS TO DGS THE FAR
GENERAL SERVICES AND THEY OF
COURSE OUR SERVER TO THE LAW
GOVERNING SYKORA. AND WE DIDN'T
MAKE IT A SPECIAL DISPENSATION
FOR THEIR JOBS ALL THAT THEN
WITH RESPECT TO THE ACTUAL SITE
AND CONDITIONS ON THE SITE. AND
WHAT MIGHT BE FOUND WE HAVE
ACTUAL AS I SAY WE'VE INITIATED
STUDIES. AND REQUEST FOR THOSE
STUDIES CAME OUT A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE TRIBES. AND OUR
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE FOR HOW WE
WILL- HANDLE ANYTHING THAT IS
FOUND. AND THERE IS ACTUALLY A
BROAD OF. MANY MANY ITEMS OF
DISCUSSION AGREEMENT THAT HAVE
A RESERVE OF THE TRIBES ALL
FORMS GUIDE THE PROJECT GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST TO REITERATE YOU BELIEVE
THAT- THE PROCESS OF AB FIFTY
TWO IS WHAT'S BEING ADHERED TO
DURING THIS WHOLE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE OF THE ANNEX WORKING WITH
LOCAL TRIBES. I BELIEVE IT. I
GENERALLY BELIEVE THAT IS THE
CASE BUT AS I SAY IT IS BY LAW
IT IS TGS HAS RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO THE SEQUEL PORTION THANK YOU
IN AND WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW
WITH THE G. S. AND PROBABLY GET
A BRIEFING- TO FIND OUT IF THAT
IS THE PROCESS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING. ON WHICH
LEADS TO MY NEXT- QUESTION IS
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
POTENTIAL MITIGATION PLAN IN
THE EVENT OF UNCOVERING- INDIAN
ARTIFACTS. AND ALSO A PLAN. TO
IN CASE THERE IS INADVERTENT
DISCOVERY OF NATIVE AMERICAN
RANGE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MITIGATION AND THAT
CONSULTATION. IS ON GOING PRIOR
TO ANY- AREAS THAT MIGHT ON
COVER THOSE TWO- AREAS OF
CULTURAL RESOURCES. CULTURAL
ARTIFACTS OR INVERT DISCOVERY
IN AN AMERICAN REMAINS YEAH. AS
I SAID THAT ACTUALLY THE ISSUE
OF. IT REMAINS WAS ADDRESSED
RAISED AS A VITAL ISSUE THIS
PROJECT IN THE DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STUDY. WE HAVE BEEN
VERY AGGRESSIVE TO. ENGAGE THE
TRIBE'S EARLIER YOU ASSISTED IN
THAT- I WOULD SAY. THERE IS
ALREADY A PLAN IN PLACE OF
COLLABORATION FOUR WE WE'VE GOT
OUR OWN DUE DILIGENCE STUDIES
THE- CADAVER DOGS THE GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR THESE WERE
THINGS UNDERTAKEN IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE TRIBES.
OF THOSE HAVEALREADY BEEN
COMPLETED AND THERE IS THE
PROTOCOL ALREADY IN PLACE FOR
WHEN THERE'S GROUND DISTURBANCE
TO HAVE TRIBAL MONITORS THAT WE
WILL PAY FOR- SO THAT'S THAT IS
A PRIORITY IT HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY DURING MY TENURE.
STARTED WITH THE DECEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PLANNING STUDY
WHICH AT MY INSISTENCE NOTED
THAT THAT WASN'T AND ELEMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARITY AND IF AT A FUTURE
MEETING- IF WE HAVE ANOTHER
MEETING JOINT RULES IF WE COULD
AGENDAS THAT COMPONENT OF IT SO
WE COULD ALL BE CLEAR ON ON
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IT AND HOW
THE DISCUSSIONS ARE. MOVING
FORWARD- IN DEALING WITH THE
TRIBAL CONSULTATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR EARNERS. YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND IT IS VERY
EXCITING WITH THANK YOU FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PROJECT I
REMEMBER WHEN I CAME IN AS A
STAFFER TO THIS BUILDING THIS
IS STILL THE INKLING PHASE OF
JUST AN IDEA AND TO SEE THAT
NOW VISUALIZE IN FRONT O US IS
QUITE EXCITING TO BE ABLE DO
THIS AND I DO THINK IT'S A
MONUMENT FOR THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO BE TAKE PRIDE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL SO I
DO THANK YOU FOR LEADERSHIP AND
BEING. ASSERTIVE ABOUT
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATORS ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS I JUST CURIOUS I
MADE A MISTAKE IN THE
OPPOSITION EARLY BUT IS THERE
AN ANTICIPATED OR GOLD DATE OF
WHEN THIS WILL BE FINISHED. HE
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE IT
CONCLUDED BY THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND THAT IS KIND OF
A PRACTICAL RULE THAT'S HOW THE
WEST WING WAS DONE YOU YOU HAVE
THIS ISSUE THOSE LAWMAKERS WE
ARE VERY BUSY IN THE CONDUCT OF
OUR WORK THE FIRST THREE
QUARTERS OF EVERY YEAR. AND IN
THE- FOURTH QUARTER OF AN EVEN
NUMBER HERE WE TYPICALLY HAVE
ELECTIONS. SO REALLY FOR THE
WHOLE PROJECT THE ONE TIME THAT
IS OPPORTUNE TO MOVE LAWMAKERS
IN MASS IS THE FOURTH QUARTER
OF AN ODD EVERY YEAR SO THAT'S-
BEEN THE TARGET- WE EXPECT THAT
STARTING NEXT YEAR WE WOULD
HAVE CONCLUDED FOR A GRAND
OPENING ON. CALIFORNIA'S ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIFTH.
BIRTHDAY ADMISSIONS DAY
SEPTEMBER NINTH TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. AND WE HAD TO HIT THAT
MARK. OR WE SUFFER A LOT OF
TURMOIL MOVING PEOPLE MIDSTREAM
OR WAITED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN AND THAT JUST ADDS DELAY
AND EXPENSE. SO THE GOAL IS.
FOURTH QUARTER TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. AND I WILL SAY THAT A
MAJOR PART OF THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN TO AGGRESSIVELY SUPPORT
STUDIES. AND PREPARATION SO-THAT WHEN WE ARE READY TO MOVE
IT AN MOVE SPEEDILY THAT'S
BEEN ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS WE
PLAYED ALL ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
IN THIS PROCESS. WHEN THINGS
TRIMMING YES PLEASE BEFORE E
GO TO BUY EXTRA. GOOD GOING TO
THE POINT OF PLANNING FOR THE
FUTURE. IN A HUNDRED YEARS YOU
MAY NOT HAVE CARS RIGHT. WE
DON'T HAVE CARS SO BUILDING A
GARAGE FOURTEEN FEET HIGH
THAT'S WHY I ASKED THE
QUESTION. YOU COULD ULTIMATELY
TURNED OTHER SPACE. WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF THAT KIND OF THINKING
ABOUT WHAT. FLEXIBILITY WE
MIGHT NEED. BECAUSE WHO KNOWS
WHAT THE FUTURE IS GOING TO
BRING BUT I SUSPECT IT WON'T
INVOLVE CARCASS. SURE THAT
OBSERVATION WITH MR- OUR SERVER
BROUGHT SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING-
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS VERY
BEAUTIFUL ALL THE THOUGHT THAT
WENT INTO IT BY YARD SIX- BASED
ON THE PRESENTATION AND MY
QUESTION IS. IT AT THE SAME
TIME THAT IS VERY BEAUTIFUL AND
ALSO LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
STERILE. AS FAR AS. YOU KNOW
POSSIBILITIES THERE AND SO I'M
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHERE THE
THOUGHT OR WHERE. AND HOW WILL
WE INCORPORATE SOME ASPECTS OF
THE CULTURE OF THE STATE RIGHT-
THE BEAUTIFUL DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE AND THE PROGRESSIVE
VALUES OF THE STATE SO I'M
CURIOUS HOW OR WHEN. THAT
CONVERSATION HAPPENS- SO THAT
IT'S MORE THAN BEAUTIFUL GLASS
AND THE AND THE AND THE
BUILDING THAT WERE RESTORING
WHICH IS OR OR WE'RE WE'RE
KEEPING AN- AND INCORPORATING
HERE BUT- HOW ELSE DO WE GO
BEYOND. THAT INTO SOMETHING
THAT MORE ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HER GOOD. I THINK ON
THAT ISSUE THERE'S A COUPLE OF
RESPONSE I WOULD SAY ARE WE
FULLY EXPECTED FOR EXAMPLE
THESE KINDS OF INTERIORS. WOULD
BE A PALETTE FOR THAT SORT OF.
ALL ARTWORK WHAT WHATEVER WE
CHOOSE TO BRING FORWARD. SO YOU
ARE CORRECT YOU ARE SEE MORE
THE STRUCTURAL ELEMENTS WITH
YOU GET ALL THESE AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE TRAVEL WE WOULD SEE THE
OPTION FOR EMBELLISHMENT. AND
SHARING THE NARRATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE OTHER PIECE I
DESCRIBED. WE DO HAVE
CONTEMPLATION. YOU KNOW THE
CAPITAL WAS ALWAYS ENVISIONED
PEOPLE TO ENTER FROM THE WEST
THAT'S WHEN IT WAS BUILT. AND
THERE IS A PLAN FOR A VISITOR
CENTER. WHICH WILL ALLOW ALL
THE GAS ALL THE TOUR GROUPS
TRAFFIC IN THE CAPITAL OF FROM
BELOW THE ENTRY PLAZA. INTO THE
BASEMENT AD HAVE THE RUN OF
THE WEST WING AND THE WHOLE
BUILDING. AND OF COURSE THE
VISITOR CENTER IS ACTUALLY SET
UP TO BE THE PLACE WHERE YOU
WOULD ESTABLISH. AND IT'S NOT
ME TO BE APPROVED FOR DRUG
RULES COMMITTEE OR MAYBE A SUB
COMMITTEE MEMBERSHIP WORK OR
THE GOVERNOR- CHARACTERIZED IN
THE NATURE OF THE STATE THE
RICHNESS OF THE STATE THE
ABUNDANCE OF THE STATE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE. AND
MAKE THAT A VERY CALIFORNIA
CENTRIC AND DEMOCRACY CENTRIC.
PLACE TO COME TO THE CAPITOL
AND DISCOVER WHAT ABOUT OUR
GREAT STATE. IT COULD BE
CULTURAL THINGS IT COULD BE
IMAGES ABOUT SHASTA OR LASSEN
OR WHITNEY HIS EXCEPTIONAL
THINGS WITHIN OUR STATE I SORT
OF THINK. I FEEL LIKE. IT'S
SORT OF LIKE ANY CHILD WHO
COMES THE STATE CAPITOL. TO SEE
SOMETHING IN THE BILL IN THEIR
MINDS OVER THERE WHERE THEY ARE
FROM. WHICH IS VERY EASY A
STATE LIKE OURS. ARM SEOUL I
PERSONALLY FEEL THAT THE
INTERIORS OF THESE BILLS BECOME
A PALETTE TO DO A LOT OF
NARRATIVE ABOUT THE STATE AND A
MARKER C. ERA AND I REALLY SEE
A VISITOR CENTER IS
PREEMINENTLY THAT. ARM AND- BUT
I DO RECOGNIZE THAT I AM
CERTAINLY TURNED OUT BY THE
FALL OF TWENTY FOUR SO OTHERS
WILL PICK UP THAT BATON IT IS
ALSO EXPECTED. WELL I WILL SAY
HERE ARE. A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION OF I'D LIKE TO SEE
HAPPEN IS. IT IS SO THE
GOVERNOR HAS AN INTEREST IN AND
I ACTUALLY SUPPORTERS STRONGLY
I KIND OF FEEL WE WOULD BE WELL
SERVED TO DEDICATE THE TWO
ROOMS ON THE FIRST FOUR OTHER
RESTORED CAPITAL. OF IN THE
NORTH WEST CORNER. TWO ROOMS
DEDICATED TO OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAID THEIR
HISTORY. AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIP. AND WHILE I FEEL
IT IS. SINCE I WAS THE TOP
STAFFER TO THE MEMBER WHO DID
THE WEST WING PROJECT. I FEEL
WHAT I CAN DO IS I'M A STRONG
PLACE TO SAY THIS WOULD BE A
GREAT. WAY TO DEDICATE TO FOUR
FOUR ROOMS TO THIS BUT ACTUALLY
THE CONTENT I FEEL THAT SOMEONE
ELSE'S CONVERSATION IS SORTED
OUT MY CONVERSATION TO LEAD.
OUR SO THAT'S A MORE VERY
SPECIALIZED PURPOSE I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT I WOULD ENVISION
THAT IN THE- IN A VISITOR
CENTER. WE WOULD PROBABLY
APPROACH IT ON THE BASIS THAT
THERE ARE. AREAS THAT ARE
DEDICATED SORT OF A YEAR AROUND
THE MESSAGE. AND IT WOULD ALSO
BE A SPACE THAT WULD BE SORT
OF A CHANGEABLE MESSAGE. AND
THAT WOULD ALLOW DIFFERENT
GROUPS DIFFERENT OUTLOOKS TO
KIND OF WORK WITH LEADERSHIP ON
DEVELOPING A SOME SORT OF
SPECIALIZED THING. AND SO ALL
OF THOSE IDEAS ARE ARE SORT OF
PART OF THE VISITOR CENTER
CONVERSATION. BUT YEAH I
STRONGLY BELIEVE WITH YOU
CENTER THAT THE IT. THIS PEOPLE
THOU SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT.
WHEN I CALIFORNIA COMES THERE
THEY SEE THEMSELVES. IN THIS IN
SOME WAY. CENTER THEY RELATE TO
AS PRESIDENT AND A PART OF THE
BUILDING. THANK YOU BILL YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHEN I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION
THAT YOU AND SENATOR ALSO JUST
HAD- AS FAR AS YOU KNOW HOW
EVERYONE VIEWS THIS BUILDING
THE NEW BUILDING. AT ITS
OBJECTIVE I THINK ONE THING
THAT GIVES US A SENSE OF PLACE
IS THE VIEW OF THE CAPITOL DOME
FROM THE ATRIUM AND I'M I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THEY HAVE. TAKEN
THAT SO EVERYONE WHO'S IN THAT
BUILDING REMEMBERS WHERE THEY
ARE AND THAT IS A VERY SPECIAL
PLACE I DO WANT TO TAKE NOTE OF
THE SECURITY CONCERNS ARE
RAISED IN IN CLOSED SESSION-
THE ISSUE THAT I WANT TO RAISE
IS ONE THAT I THINK- CENTER
HERTZBERG. USED A VERY
IMPORTANT ORD JUST RECENTLY HE
TALKED ABOUT FLEXIBILITY ABOUT
THE BUILDING PARTICULARLY ABOUT
THE FUTURE. AND IF YOU LOOK AT-
THE WAY THAT WE LEGISLATE THERE
ARE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
LAWMAKERS FOR STATE OF FORTY
MILLION- UPON ENTRY- THE STATE
HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND AT
THE TURN OF THE LAST CENTURY.
ABOUT A MILLION AND WE MAY HAVE
SIXTY EIGHTY MILLION PEOPLE
REPRESENTIN THE FUTURE. THE
HUNDRED TWENTY LAWMAKERS IS
BAKED INTO OUR OUR CONSTITUTION
BUT THERE COULD BE A TIME. WHEN
WE DETERMINE THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENT NUMBER OF LAWMAKERS
AND OF COURSE FLEXIBILITY IN
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WE HAVE NOT
EMBRACED DURING THE PANDEMIC-
CERTAINLY IN THE FUTURE WOULD
WOULD BE HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
WE DON'T. ENGAGE IN NOT
FLEXIBILITY A LITTLE BIT MORE.
BUT THAT. HOW DO WE TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHAT THAT ANNEX
WILL BE LIKE FOR A POTENTIAL-
YOU KNOW THE- LEGISLATURE THAT
MIGHT BE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
TWENTY LAWMAKERS. I THINK
THAT'S A VERY. FORWARD LOOKING
WHO CANNOT DISMISS IT OUR-
AGAIN THIS I'M ONLY THE DRIVER
DURING THIS TIME IT ACTUALLY
STARTED- MY PREDECESSOR AND
FIRST OF ALL IT'LL PICK
MCCONNELL PASSED TO SOMEONE
ELSE I THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATURE ARE. I SORT OF
ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD THE TIME IN THE SWING
SPACE WHILE THIS BUILDING GETS
ADDRESSED WE WILL MOVE BACK I
WOULD ANTICIPATE THE FOLKS IN
L. O. V. WILL THEN MOVE INTO
THE- SWING SPACE. AND THEN L.
BE WILL GET ADDRESS BECAUSE IT
ALSO HAS ISSUES. THE STATUTE BY
WHICH WE AUTHORIZED TGS TO
PURSUE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SWING SPACE. INCLUDED LANGUAGE
THAT REFERRED TO THE FACT THAT
IT WAS ANTICIPATED THERE WOULD
BE A LONG TERM NOT DEFINE JOINT
OCCUPANCY OF THAT BUILDING BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ALL THE POTENTIAL
THAT THAT MINE WAS ACTUALLY TO
SUPPORT THE L. B. PROJECT TO BE
HONEST BUT IT IS SOMEWHAT OPEN
ENDED SO THERE'S THERE IS SOME
FLEXIBILITY WE ARE NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF- AS A CAPITAL CAMPUS
PARTY TO HAVE. WELL DESIGNED
BUILDINGS THAT ARE CLOSER AT
HAND I. SO I THINK THERE IS
BASED UPON THE WORK OF FLORIDA
THERE THERE IS POTENTIAL- FOR
DEALING WITH THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS. I IN MY EXPERIENCE. THE
ONCE IT BECOMES EVIDENT THAT
THERE IS A D. THE LEGISLATURE
TO WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR WILL
FIND A SOLUTION- YOU KNOW ALL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE AT A MINIMUM
ALTHOUGH WOULD REQUIRE. IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONCLUDED THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND THE BILL
THE GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR
DOESN'T SIGN IT WILL DO AN
OVERRIDE. AND THAT IS THE ONE
ON CHECK BOX IN THE NEW
GENERATION OF LAWMAKERS AS A
YOUNG MAN I WORK WITH. A MEMBER
OF THE DIDN'T OVERRIDE AB FIVE
MEETING I REMEMBER VERY
CLEARLY. A POLICY BACK RIGHT SO
WE DO HAVE A TOOL IN OUR TOOL
KIT IS AN INSTITUTION. TO
REALLY FORCE AN ISSUE IF WE
FELT WE HAD IN THE- THAT'S WHAT
I THINK THAT THAT'S NOT REALLY
THE POINT I SUPPOSE A POTENTIAL
WAY TO THE BRAINS FROM IT THIS
IS THAT EXTRA SPACE WOULD
EITHER BE. WHAT WE CALL THE
SWING SPACE NOW BUT COULD BE
THE L. O. B. AS AN EXTRA
BUILDING FOR MORE MEMBERS IF
THAT. IS THE NEED OF THE
LEGISLATURE OR ADDITIONAL.
OFFICE SPACE HOWEVER YOU WANT
TO DESCRIBE THAT. PETER THAT'S
RIGHT LOOK. TWENTY YEARS AGO
THERE WERE THIRTY TWO UNITED
STATES SENATORS AND A HUNDRED
EIGHT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THOSE THINGS CHANGE I
COMPLETELY AGREE I THINK THAT.
ON THE ONE HAND WE WORK HARD TO
CREATE AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY-
LIKE THAT WORD THANK YOU. IN
THIS PROCESS BY. DEALING WITH
THE NEAR TERM THING OF CARS AND
THE LIKE AND- WHAT WE THINK
COULD BE THE CASE BUT THERE'S A
PROPOSALS PROPOSAL RECENTLY
INCREASE THE LEGISLATURE TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS RECENTLY ON
THE BALLOT. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN WORK OUTSIDE THE PARAMETERS
OF THE CONSTITUTION AND MAKE
THOSE KINDS OF DETERMINATIONS
WILL WORKING REMOTELY TODAY WHO
KNOWS WHAT THAT WORKS CAN LOOK
LIKE. I THINK WE CAN ONLY GO
KIND OF AS FAR AS WE CAN.
LOOKING AROUND THOSE CORNERS
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
TECHNOLOGY AND EVERY LEVEL GET
AS MUCH DIMENSION THERE'S
POSSIBLE GET AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE. AND IF
IN THE FUTURE. WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE A YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW I
MEAN I WOULD LOVE TO BE IN A
SITUATION WE CREATE THAT LEVEL
OF FLEXIBILITY- SHOVING BUT- I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH FOR THAT
WOULD GO WITH THAN THAT. IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THE
HYPOTHETICALS BUT I'LL SAY THIS
MUCH. IT IS CERTAINLY- BEEN IN
MY MIND AND EXPLORE THOSE
THOUGHTS BUT IT'S KIND OF THIS
LIMITED BY SOME PRACTICAL
REALITIES. AND I THINK WE CAN
GO AS FAR AS WE CAN. IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TODAY.
ADA ACCESS EARTHQUAKE ACCESS-
AND WHAT'S COLDER. DISPATCH
THIS IN ALL KINDS OF THINGS
THAT CHALLENGES OUR STAFFING
HEALTH OF OUR STAFF. CHALLENGES
MEMBERS. AND I THINK GETTING
PAST THOSE THINGS. ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT IN THE NEAR TERM SO
I HOPE THAT HELPS A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU. NO ONE OF THE COME
SYSTEM IT IT'S LIKE. THIS IS
ACTUALLY A VERY FITTING THING
FOR THE MEMBERS OF DRUG RULES
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE ARE.
CUSTODIANS OF THE INSTITUTION.
BECAUSE ACTUAL WHAT THE
BUILDING WHAT WHAT A
LEGISLATIVE BUILDING NEEDS. IT
IS TO BE A FACILITY SITES IN
SUCH A WAY THAT. YOU CAN HAVE
MEMBERS. AND OF A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR HAVE THE CAN
HAVE THEIR COMMITTEE STAFF NEAR
AT HAND. BECAUSE ACTUALLY
CHAIRMAN CHAIRWOMAN WHO HAVE
THEIR STAFF BECOME MORE
EFFECTIVE IS CHEERS WE ARE
UNDER TERM LIMITS WE ARE
SUBJECT TO TWELVE YEARS MAXIMUM
WE APPOINT SOMEONE A CHAIR TO
SUPPORT A MEMBER BY LETTING
THEM HAVE READ READY ACCESS TO
THEIR STAFF NOT ACROSS THE
STREET BUT RIGHT IN THE
BUILDING ACTUALLY SUPPORTS THE
QUALITY OF LAWMAKERS SUPPORTS
THE FITNESS THE STRENGTH OF
THAT CHAIR OVERTIME. SO REALLY
A MAJOR PART OF THIS PROJECT IS
TO MOVE THE INSTITUTION BACK IN
A DIRECTION WHERE. CHAIRS AND
STAFF CAN BE COLOCATED AS A WAY
TO KIND OF STRENGTHENED THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK AND YOU SORT
OF PLAY THAT OUT OF YOUR SAID
OURS IS LIKE IT'S MORE THAN
JUST HOUSING OF MEMBERS IT'S
LIKE A SOCIAL FACILITIES AND TO
BE HONEST I THINK PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT A PART OF A LECTURE
DON'T ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND. THE
WAY SOME OF THESE THINGS WORK
TOGETHER TO STRENGTHEN LAWMAKER.
SIDE LOOKING INTO THE FUTURE
WOULD HATE TO THINK THAT- ANY
MEMBERS THAT ARE PUT INTO THE
SWING SPACE FOR THE ELEVATOR IN
THE DOG HOUSE. YEAH THAT- THERE
JUST MIGHT BE A SPACE AND
FLEXIBILITY ISSUE AND THAT
THAT'S- THAT'S SOMETHING TO
CONTEMPLATE FOR THE FUTURE YEAH
NO IT'S GOOD I WANT TO QUOTE
MARK TWAIN WHO SAID THE MAN
WITH A NEW IDEA IS A CRANK.
UNTIL IT SUCCEEDS AND I WANT TO
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING THE L.
O. B. OUT OF GOVERNOR WILSON
WAY BACK WHEN- WHEN THAT WAS
FOR LIKE A NEW IDEA. AND NOW
IT'S BECOME INTEGRATED OUR
BRACES SO NO LONGER CRANK A
CENTERS FOR YEAH FELT LIKE ONE
OF THE TIME. BUT YOU KNOW JUST
JUST YOU KNOW GO AGAIN IN
HAVING THIS KIND OF MORE
DETAILED DISCUSSION ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THERE WAS AS WE AS
AN INSTITUTION CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT PEOPLE AND SET STANDARDS
IN THE LIKE WE MOVED OUT OF
THIS HOUSE SIXTEEN COMMITTEES
ACROSS FLORIDA. BECAUSE
PEOPLE'S WORKING CONDITIONS ARE
SO DIFFICULT AND CREATED NEW
AND BETTER OFFICES FOR MEMBERS-
THAT WEREN'T SO CRAMPED AND
GAVE IT A CAN YOU GIVE
CONFERENCE ROOMS HAVE A PLACE
TO EAT- AND THE LIKE AND IN A
CHILD CARE CENTER. TO DO THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS DEALING WITH
THE THOSE ISSUES SO YOU'RE
RIGHT WE BOTTOM FROM PUBLIC
GOVERNOR WILSON WHATEVER YEAR
THAT WAS I CAN'T REMEMBER
TOWARD ON THE ONE IN THE BACK
WHICH IS NOW. THE SPACE FOR THE
SWING SPACE. AND WE HAVE ALL.
EXCEPT TO YOU'VE GOT THE SET
HERE REPRESENTS A DISTRICT YEAH.
CENTER THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
WHILE CERTAINLY ENOUGH LONG
ENOUGH TO ENJOY THE NEW
BUILDING IT WILL BE IT IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I'LL BE LOOKING AT
IT AS THE RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO
FOR A VERY LONG TIME I'M SURE-
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APOLOGIZE I WASN'T ABLE TO BE
THERE FOR. ANOTHER HEARING
GOING ON- POLICY HEARING BUT I
DID HAVE A- SO FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU- ONE OF THINGS THAT'S
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE PAID ATTENTION
TO IS SERVE BOTH PUT THE FLOW
THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO SAFETY. AS
WELL- KNOWING THAT- BUT I GUESS
MIKE WHAT THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
AND AGAIN I'M JUST LOOKING AT
PICTURES OF RENDERINGS AND SO
FORTH YOU KNOW IT IS IN
SACRAMENTO AND- SACRAMENTO GETS
VERY HOT IN THE SUMMER. AS WELL
INCLUDING IN AUGUST WE DO END
OF SESSION I SEE A LOT OF GLASS
THERE- SO YOU MAY HAVE RATED
DRESS THIS BUT PERHAPS YOU CAN
TOUCH ON A YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GO FOR A BETTER
CLIMATE FUTURE AND SO FORTH AND
SO- IN TERMS OF ITS- ENERGY OF
BALANCE AND DID I WAS WONDERING
LIKE DO WE HAVE AND AGAIN I'M
NOT ARCHITECT SO IT WE- HAD. TO
HAVE MORE- LIKE HEAT HEAT SINKS
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT
HELP US REDUCE OUR ENERGY USE
WHILE ALSO KEEPING THE BUILDING
COOL EFFICIENTLY ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PARTICULARLY HOT DRY
SUMMERS WE HAVE HERE HOOKED
RIGHT WHETHER WE HAVE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SO IT'S MORE
EFFECTIVE. SACRAMENTO'S AT
KLEINER. AND MAKE IT HARDER.
GOING TO THE TO VERY GOOD
CENTER WILL ONE OF THE- OF THE
VERY. GOES WE WILL HAVE AMONG
MOST ENTERED EFFICIENT CAPITALS.
IN THE NATION. AND RATED HIGH
FROM LEAD STANDPOINT BUT LET ME
TURN TO. MR PLUS HILLS. WOULD
MAKE. THEY'RE VERY OFTEN. MHM
THANK OF THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION THEN- THERE ARE MANY
ASPECTS TO THE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION OF THE OPERATIONS
OF THE BUILDING ONE OF WHICH IS
THE PERFORMANCEOF THE EXTERIOR
WALL AS YOU MENTIONED THE GLASS
COULD BE AN ISSUE- THE WAY THE
BUILDING IS A SIGN IS ABOUT.
THEY SAVE YOU VERY CLOSE TO A
6040% RATIO OF- VISION GLASS IN
WHAT WE CALL THE SPEND OF LESS
OPAQUE BLACK. SO THAT-
OBVIOUSLY REDUCES THE AMOUNT
OF- SOLAR HEAT RADIATION THAT
COMES IN ANOTHER ASPECT OF- OF
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT EXISTS
TODAY IS AT THE HIGH PRICE
PERFORMANCE OF THE GLASS. THAT
IS THAT IS. EXISTING TODAY IS
A- VERY VERY- HIGH PERFORMANCE
IN TERMS OF MITIGATING SOLAR
HEAT GAIN. AND AT THE SAME TIME
ALLOWING DAYLIGHT TO COME IN.
AS YOU KNOW ANOTHER- CONDITION
OF ENERGY OPERATIONAL EXPENSES
ARE THE LIGHTS RIGHT WHEN WE
BRING THEY LIGHT IDEALLY. YOU
CAN TURN THE LIGHTS OFF AND NOT
EXPEND THAT ENERGY SO WE WANNA
HARVEST THAT THEY LIKE AND WE
WANT TO MITIGATE THAT GLARE AT
WHICH WE DO WHAT WE CALL A
FRIEND TO PATTERN THAT IS
APPLIED TO THE- INSIDE SURFACE
OF THE GLASS. THAT ALSO
REFLECTS THAT HEAT OUT SO IT IS
A VERY HIGH PERFORMANCE
EXTERIOR WALL. IN GENERAL ON.
ALL ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT. WE
HAVE FOR RAISE THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE OUR PARTNERS WE DO ONE
ENERGY EFFICIENT BUILDING FOR
EXAMPLE. BUT WE FOR A SAID WELL
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAS IT IN
CUTTING EDGE CALIFORNIA STATE
CALIPHATE EXHIBIT. WELL
UNDERSTOOD OUTSTANDING DESIGN
BUT NOT BLEEDING EDGE NOT SOUL
SO FAR OUT THERE THAT YOU YOU
HAVE A TECHNOLOGICAL FAIL. SO
IT'S SORT OF A FORWARD LOOKING
BUT WITH THE CONSERVATIVE BENT-
BUT ON THE ISSUE OF GLASSES
VERY. I WOULD SAY WE'RE SEEING
A LOT MORE USE OF HIGH
PERFORMANCE CLASSES IN
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE- THE FACT
IS PEOPLE LIKE WORK AND WHERE
THEY SEE SUNLIGHT SO THERE'S
SORT OF A WORK FORCE
CONSIDERATION. PROVIDE MORE
NATURAL LIGHTING THAT CAN
ACCESS THE SWEETS CERVANTES
COULDN'T CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
DIED DON'T OBJECT TO A CLASS IN
ITSELF- THE MATERIAL HI IT'S
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THE NO THE
MASS OF THE BUILDING AND HOW
CAN REPRESENTS THE HEAT SAYING.
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW LIGHTS THE
PRESENCE OF PEOPLE GENERATES
HEAT AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
I APPRECIATE THAT AND EVEN I
UNDERSTAND YOU CAN HAVE NOW PUT
GLASS PANES AND AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW HOW HORRIBLE IT IS. THAT
ACTUALLY A SOLAR PANELS THAT
ALSO ACT AS WINDOW PANES AS
WELL SO THE DEGREE WE CAN EVEN
GENERATE ENERGY- WITH THE
APPROPRIATE TYPE OF. PANELS
AGAIN WHETHER IT'S A COST
EFFICIENT OR NOT I DON'T KNOW
BUT- I THINK IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL- BUT THOSE
ARE GOING TO. SEND RAZA IS
COMMON ALSO WAS WE WANT THIS
GOING TO BE WARM AND INVITING
WHY IS IT WARM NOT JUST KEEP
HIGHS BUT YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE WALKING N. THIS NOT SO
TECHNOLOGY IS GREAT ON THE BIG
PHONE IT DOES PROPONENT OF-
HIGH TECHNOLOGY- BUT ALSO WE
WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL WELCOME
WHEN THEY WALK IN AND SO AN
OPPOSING GLASS STRUCTURE AGAIN
I'M NOT A PHYSICAL LAST. NOTE
EXACTLY WHAT THE TONES AND SO
FORTH NAY MAY CREATE THAT SENSE
OF IS IT JUST A BIG INSTITUTION
THAT HOW MOST PEOPLE VIEW THE
STATE OR IS IT SOMETHING THAT
THEY HAVE TO FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE OWNERSHIP OVER SO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. I DO WANT TO SAY I
THINK THAT IS WE DEFINITELY ALL
WANT A WELCOMING BUILDING. AND
ONE IS I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT LIKE.
THE TALK ABOUT THAT EAST ENTRY.
AT THE- IT JUSTIFIES. IF YOU'RE
ON THE OUTSIDE. YOU DO SEE THE
GLASS. BUT THEN YOU SEE. THAT
LARGE ASSEMBLY AREA UNDER A
SKYLIGHT. AND I ACTUALLY THINK
IF YOU EVER BEEN IN A PLACE
WHERE YOU'RE ON THE OUTSIDE
LOOKING IN AND YOU SEE LIKE
FALLING. AHEAD OF YOU THAT
ITSELF TO SORT OF DRAW YOU IN.
IT LOOKS LIKE OKAY I CAN GO IN
THERE. SO I DO THINK THAT. YOU
KNOW IT SEEMS SORT OF HOKEY.
BUT THE STAIRCASES IN THE WEST
WING ON THE NEW WILL POST HAVE
THOSE PINEAPPLES THAT ARE
CARVED IN THE WOOD. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IF YOU WERE TRAVELING
MISTER CASES YOU'D WALK PAST SO
SUSPENDED PINEAPPLES. AND THAT
WAS A SYMBOL OF WELCOME. THAT'S
HOW YOU MOVE AROUND THE BILL IN
EVERY TURNER'S A PINEAPPLE
THERE'S SORT OF A WELCOMING
REMINDER. THAT'S VERY MUCH ONE
OF THE GOALS. THAT THE L. AND
THE CITY FOR THE VISITOR
CENTER. YOU KNOW YOU THINK FOR
ALL THE KIDS WHO COME HERE.
WHAT ASIDE FOR OUR OUR MOST
AUGUST SELVES THAT'S A JOKE OUR
IS THE EXPERTS REALLY
EDUCATIONAL ABOUT OUR DEMOCRACY
OR CELEBRATORY ABOUT THE STATE
AND ITS RICHES- THE MANY MANY
QUALITIES THAT OUR STATE HAS
THAT'S ALL SOMETHING THAT WE
HOPE THE INTEGRATED BUILDING
BAD FIGHT FRANKLY I FEEL THAT'S
A WORK OF MY COLLEAGUES. WILL
HELP WITH. THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY ARM. WELL THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE- THANK YOU MEMBERS WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
I WANT TO SAY WE HAVE A TWO
MINUTE LIMIT ON ALL PUBLIC
COMMENTS AS WE NEED TO WRAP UP
SOARING CLEAN CLEAN THE
CHAMBERS ADVANCE OF SESSION AT
ONE PM TODAY. ARM SOUL WE HAVE
MEMBERS. OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK. JUST PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS DRUMMING
SALINAS HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED AUBURN INDIAN
COMMUNITY- TODAY I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS ON AND
OPPOSITION TO THE PROJECT-
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID TODAY
AS FAR AS TRIBAL CONCERNS-
WORDS I WANT TO FOCUS ON THIS
WERE POTENTIAL THE
ARCHAEOLOGICAL POTENTIAL. OF
WHAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE FOUND
ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS VERY SAD
TO NOTE THAT THE WORDS OF OUR
TRIBAL ELDERS THE WORDS OF THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL. THE WORDS OF
THE TRIBAL HISTORIC
PRESERVATION OFFICER FROM
UNITED AUBURN ARE DISCOUNTED.
AND LOOKED AWAY. THE TRIBE WAS
HERE. THE PEOPLE LIVE HERE THEY
INHABITED THIS AREA SOUGHT
POTENTIAL. IT IS WHAT IT IS
THEY HAVE THE HISTORY HERE. YOU
KNOW WHAT'S THE POINT OF TIME
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT- THEY
WORK TO ERADICATE THE TRIBES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW IT'S SAD TO SEE THAT ONCE
AGAIN THE GOVERNMENT IS AGAIN
COMING TO. DISCOUNT THE HISTORY
AND CULTURE OF THE TRIBE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
WE ARE PAUSING AS ANOTHER
WITNESS. PROCEDURE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON- I'M RICHARD CAL
ONE FORMER CHAIR OF THE STORK
STATE CAPITAL COMMISSION I'M
HERE TODAY IS A VOLUNTEER WITH
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUR
CAPITAL WE TOO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROJECT AS
YOU'VE CURRENTLY CREATED IT- I
NOTICED SIGNIFICANT NEW
INFORMATION RECEIVED TODAY.
IT'LL TAKE US A LITTLE TIME TO
DIGEST THAT- MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
IS VERY HUNGRY. TO HEAR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROJECT
IS THE VISITOR CENTER
COMPLETELY OFF THE TABLE IS IT
NOW PART OF THE ANNEX. CAN YOU
SHARE THE SCHEDULE. CAN YOU
SHARE THE COSTS. WE'D LIKE TO
KNOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY. VERY GOOD ONE
MOMENT. HELLO MY NAME IS KATE
RILEY I AM A REPRESENTING- ALSO
VOLUNTEER WITH PAC AND
REPRESENTING TREES FOR
SACRAMENTO ALSO WORKED IN THE
ASSEMBLY FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS-
WE WANT TO JUST SAY THAT WE ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PLAN- OUR ESTIMATE IS
THAT T. STREET- THE TO THE
DOUBLE T. DESIGN WHICH IS WHAT
YOU'VE APPEARED OF SELECTED. IS
THE ONE OF THE THREE THAT WERE
CONSIDERED IN SEPTEMBER THAT
REMOVED THE MOST TREES WE IF
YOU DO NOT DO THE VISITOR
CENTER THERE WILL STILL BE AT
LEAST FIFTY FIVE TREES LARGE
AND SMALL REMOVED- THREATENED
DUE TO THE DOUBLETREE ANNEX
BUILDING AND THE TWELFTH ST
UNDERGROUND PARKING GARAGE SOME
OF THEM MIGHT IT MAY INCLUDE A
GIGANTIC SIKORA TWO HISTORIC
HOMES THE LAST REMAINING OLD
MAGNOLIA MAGNOLIA AND A
COCKSPUR CORAL TREE. THAT WILL
BE REMOVED IF THE TWELFTH
STREET PARKING GARAGE IS BUILT
THAT CORAL TREES THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA AND IS LISTED AS AN
INTERNATIONAL MONUMENTAL TREE
OVER SEVENTEEN FEET AROUND AT
THE AT THE TRUNK NOW IF IT IT
MAY BE PROPOSED FOR BEING MOVED
BUT MOVING IS NOT THE SAME
THING IS SAVING WHEN YOU HAVE A
TREE OF THAT SIZE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO MOVE THOSE TREES
AND SO YOU MAY OPTIMISTICALLY
SAY THEY ARE SLATED FOR TO BE
pMOVED BUT THEY MADE THAT AND-
THEN PARRIS WITHIN YEARS. SO WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT. ANYTHING
THAT MOVES BEYOND THE EXISTING
FOOTPRINT. OF THE STATE OF THE
CAP THE HISTORIC CAPITOL ANNEX
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW. THIS
COMPLEX IS SURROUNDED BY TREES
AND SO ANYTIME YOU GO OUTSIDE
THE FOOTPRINT YOU'RE
ENDANGERING TREES. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT. WE ARE GLAD TO
SEE THAT THE VISITOR CENTERS IS
NOT IN THE SLIDES. BECAUSE THAT
WOULD ALSO BRING ABOUT A
DESTRUCTION OF TREES AS WELL
AS- OF THE WEST PLAZA MEETING
PLACE. AND SO WE THINK THAT. WE
ARE ASKING THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. TO REJECT THE IDEA
OF EXPANDING THE FOOTPRINT OF
THE ANNEX AND TO REJECT THE
VISITOR CENTER AND THE
UNDERGROUND PARKING GARAGE AND
INSTEAD. WORK TO REDUCE RE.
APPEAL THE BILL TATE AND
RESTORE. THE EXISTING AND
HISTORIC ANNEX BUILDING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
COMMON SHARES IN THE CHAMBERS.
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THREE STEP PLAN WITH
TREES FOR SACRAMENTO- AND A
FORMER LEGISLATIVE STAFFER.
RESEARCH AGENCY SECRETARY AND
DEPARTMENT EXECUTIVE- I WANT TO
ASK WHAT THE ACTION IS BEING
TAKEN TODAY ON THIS PROJECT
WE'VE ASKED FOR BACKGROUND
INFORMATION. FOR JUSTIFICATION
OF THE DEMOLITION AND HAVE BEEN
REFUSED OUR LEGISLATIVE. OPEN
RECORDS ACT REQUEST WE WOULD
LIKE TO NARROW- WHY THE PUBLIC
CAN'T SEE YOUR JUSTIFICATION
FOR DEMOLITION OF THE ANNEX
BUILDING. ALSO THE ANNEX
WEBSITE LACKS FULL REPORTS FROM
YOUR CONSULTANTS SO IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND OUT WHAT
THIS PROJECT IS AN IMPACT TODAY.
YOU HAVEN'T EVEN TALKED ABOUT
THE VISITOR CENTER AS FAR AS WE
KNOW. AND YET IT'S IN THE ER
AND WILL BE APPROVED WHEN THE
ER INSIDE. SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THE
TOTAL PROJECT. FINALLY UNLIKE
OTHER STATE PROJECTS WHICH I'VE
WORKED ON IN MY PAST. THIS
PROJECT HAS HAD NO FISCAL
OVERSIGHT. NO REVIEW BY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LMAO AND
THE CLASS OF THIS BUILDING
SINCE WE ESTIMATE IS ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER SQUARE FOOT. COMPARED TO
OTHER STATE BUILDINGS THAT HAD
REVIEW SUCH AS YOUR SWING
BUILDING. WHICH IS NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS PER SQUARE
FOOT WHICH WAS MORE REASONABLE.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE COSTS
ARE GROWING AND HAVE DOUBLED IN
TWO YEARS AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE
A FULL EXPLANATION AND
DISCUSSION OF THAT. AND FINALLY
THE VISITOR CENTER ALONE HS
GONE UP TO SAID EIGHT MILLION.
FOR IF WE COULD GET ANSWERS ON
THE FROM WE APPRECIATE TO SHARE
WITH THE PUBLIC YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OR I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU IN THE GAS FOR YOUR
PART OF TODAY AND- WE NOW GO TO
THE PHONE INES OF I REQUEST OF
THE MODERATE REMIND CALLERS HOW
TO OPEN THIR LINES AND WE HAVE
A TWO MINUTE. COMMENT PERIOD.
THANK YOU WATER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT THE CHAIR. BOOKERS TELL
ME THAT ONE DIDN'T THEIR ROLES
TO HAVE TO MAKE A COMMENT WHAT
THAT MEANS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS. DO WE HAVE A
PARTICIPANT. YES SIR THAT'S
SHOWING UP NOW WE'RE GIVING
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT OF THE CHAIR. AB ONE
SECOND IS THE CHAIR. THANK YOU
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT. FROM
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANTHONY I AM A CERTIFIED
ARBORIST WITHIN A FULL SPECIAL
OCCASION. BY CHAIR THE
PREFERABLE VALLEY CHAPTER OF
THE CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST
COUNCIL- I WOULD WITHIN A
TWENTY MINUTE WALK OF THE
CAPITAL AND I REPRESENT URBAN.
FORESTRY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WELL FOR SEVERAL I'D GET INTO-OF CAPITOL. TO REGIONAL AND
NATIONAL GROUPS. PLANNERS URBAN
FORESTRY PROFESSIONALS AS WELL
MANY COMMUNITY AND GARDEN CLUBS.
OF THE TREES ON THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDS ARE SIMPLY PHENOMENAL.
MANY HAVE HISTORIC SIGNIFICANCE
OTHER REPRESENTS YET ANOTHER
NATION. AND THE FEW OF THE
OTHERS SPEAKERS OF MENTIONED ON
SEVERAL OUR FIRE. SO ONE OF A
KIND- OF. LIKE A STATE
REPRESENT. THE OFTEN DIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. I READ THE
PROPOSAL AND I'VE LISTENED IN
ON PREVIOUS PROJECT UPDATE. BUT
A TRYING TO WATCH TODAY BY THE
LIVE STREAM- IT WAS UNAVAILABLE
I TRIED BOTH ON APPLE AND PC SO
I COULD NOT FOLLOW ALONG
VISUALLY BUT I COULD RESURGENT-
I ALSO TRY TO GET INFORMATION
FROM THE- THE WEBSITE I HAVE TO
TELL YOU JUST- IT REALLY LACKS
COMPREHENSIVE. INFORMATION THAT
ANOTHER. BAKER MENTIONED THAT
JUST. HOME AND IT OF THE OTHER
MRS I TO ECHO THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT- BEING ABLE TO- LOOK AT
THE BUDGET FOR THIS PROJECT IF
IT IS A IS NOT AVAILABLE AND IT
REALLY SHOULD BE ON FOOT THIS
POINT- I IDEA. RIGHT OPPOSED TO
THIS PLAN AND THIS PROCESS THE
PROCESS ITSELF THE- BUT HAS NOT
DOES NOT FEEL TRANSPARENT- AND-
WITH THAT MIGHT MAKE CERTAIN OF
HEIGHTENED ABOUT WHAT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND A LACK OF
INFORMATION ABOUT WHY. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
OKAY THEN THE ALL WE HAVE THREE
PARTICIPANTS OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING ON THE STEPS. STAFF
THE NEW. WHAT ON. ALL RIGHT
HERE WE DID AUDIO. HELLO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS- BRUCE LEE I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO
TECH TAX COUNTY- TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION- JUST INSIDE AND
PERHAPS I SHOULD THE STATE A
FEW MOMENTS LONGER- BUT I
THOUGHT THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
GOING A BIT LONG SO I CAME
OUTSIDE BUT FORTUNATELY I CAN
STILL DRESS YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OUR FOCUS TO IT WITH THE
SECOND TO TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
IS TO. LOOK AT PROTECTING-
TAXPAYERS RIGHTS AND LOOKING AT
USING OUR TAX DOLLARS AS WISELY
AS POSSIBLE. AND I'VE ACTUALLY
WORKED IN THIS- CAPITOL
BUILDING FOR MANY MANY YEARS AS
YOU HAVE- WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND WHEN
I WOULD ASK QUESTIONS- WHEN I
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD COME TO ME
THAT BE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THERE OR GREATER. I
ALWAYS HAD TWO QUESTIONS ONE
WAS DOES THIS MAKE SENSE AND
SECONDLY IS. WORTH THE MONEY
COMING FROM. AND I'M AFRAID IN
THE INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE
KAPPA ANNEX PROJECT THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED RIGHT NOW THAT
WERE FAILING ON BOTH THOSE
COUNTS. OF NOW IS REALLY A
PIVOTAL TIME TO FOCUS ON OUR
ECONOMY AND THE RECOVERY OF OUR
ECONOMY- WE'RE PLEASED THAT
THERE IS A- STATE BUDGET
SURPLUS THAT MAY ALLOW US TO-
HELP- TEND TO THE NEEDS OF
CITIZENS. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE RECOVERY PROCESS IS GOING
TO BE A VERY LONG LONG ROAD.
AND THIS IS A PROJECT. AND THE
RESTORATION OF THE ANNEX IS
IMPORTANT BUT THERE ARE LIKELY
VERY. A NUMBER OF PLAUSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE LESS
COSTLY AND WHAT IS BEING
PROPOSED AT THIS TIME-
TAXPAYERS HAVE HAD TO TIGHTEN
THEIR BELTS DURING THE PANDEMIC
STORM. AND LIKE WISE WE NEED TO
BE VERY THOUGHTFUL IN HOW WE
APPROACH THIS AND OTHER OTHER
SPENDING PROJECTS- WE HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THIS IS
GOING TO BE A PROPOSAL THAT IS
GOING TO BE A BURDEN
FINANCIALLY UPON THIS STATE FOR
DECADES TO COME- SO IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE'RE
ESTIMATING THE COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR MILLION. BY
A TWENTY TWENTY THAT COST
ESTIMATE IS OVER ONE BILLION
AND GROWING AND I THINK YOU CAN
ALL AGREE THAT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS CAN GO A LONG WAY TO
ASSISTING THE CITIZENS OF OUR
STATE. YEAH WE HAVE MANY OTHER
PROJECT PRIORITIES PROGRAM
PRIORITIES WILDFIRE FORCE
PROTECTION PLANS ZERO MISSION
AND- VEHICLE GOALS RELIEF FOR
SMALL BUSINESS. THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT ARE ARE CRITICAL
FOR A STATE. AND AT THIS TIME I
DON'T WANT TO FOR THIS TYPE OF
PROJECT AT THIS POINT IN TIME
IT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
DELAYED IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE
DONE BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS-
WAS BEING PREVIOUSLY SUGGESTED.
ANY PERSONALLY FOR YOUR CAR
ALSO SAID ON WHETHER OR NOT A
TWO MINUTE RULE. IF YOU COULD
CONCLUDE.
WHEN IS IT MY TURN.
I'M READY TO GO EXCELLENT RIGHT
NOW SO I DON'T SIDE THE
BUILDING TODAY. WHEN IS IT MY
TURN. THIS IS CONFUSING TO ME
WHAT'S GOING ON. DO I SPEAK.
WHEN IS IT MY TURN. YES EVEN IT
OUT WELL IF I'M A DOG AND I'M
ALSO OUTSIDE THE BUILDING TODAY
I WAS DENIED ENTRANCE TO THE
BUILDING I WAS IN THE BUILDING
THURSDAY I WAS IN THE BUILDING
FRIDAY AND TODAY I WAS DENIED
ENTRANCE SO APPARENTLY I'M
STANDING HERE IN THE TENT OF
SHAME TO GIVE MY PUBLIC.
COMMENTS THOSE WHO ALREADY WALK
SUBMISSIVE LEE WILL SAY THERE
IS NO CAUSE FOR ALARM. BUT
SUBMISSIVENESS IS NOT OUR
HERITAGE. THE FIRST AMENDMENT
WAS DEVELOPED DESIGNS TO ALLOW
REBELLION TO REMAIN AS OUR
HERITAGE THE CONSTITUTION WAS
DENIED DID WAS DESIGNED TO KEEP
GOVERNMENT OFF THE BACKS OF THE
PEOPLE THE BILL OF RIGHTS WAS
ADDED TO KEEP THE PRECINCTS OF
BELIEF AND EXPRESSION. THE
PRESS OF POLITICAL AND SOCIAL
ACTIVITIES FREE FROM
SURVEILLANCE THE BILL OF RIGHTS
WAS DESIGNED TO KEEP AGENTS OF
GOVERNMENT AND OFFICIAL
EAVESDROPPERS AWAY FROM THE
ASSEMBLIES OF PEOPLE THE AIM
WAS TO ALLOW MEN TO BE FREE AND
INDEPENDENT. AND TO ASSERT
THEIR RIGHTS AGAINST CORRUPT
GOVERNMENTS LAYERED AND TATUM
FORO EIGHT U. S. ONE NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO I WAS DENIED
ENTRANCE TODAY TO THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE TO A PUBLIC HEARING. THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY OF THIS
PROJECT IS SO SHAMEFUL I DON'T
EVEN KNOW HAT TO SAY ABOUT IT
I WAS IN THIS BUILDING KEN
COOLEY WITH MY CHILDREN WHOM
YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU ARE MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON FRIDAY. AND
YOU POST THIS STUFF AT FIVE P.
M. CAN HOW CAN YOU FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THIS THE FIRST TIME I MET
YOU YOU CALLED THE POLICE ON ME
IN A PUBLIC PARK I WAS HOLDING
MY TWO YEAR OLD AND YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU SAID TO ME. YOUR
LOYALTY WAS TO THE PARTY CAN WE
THE PEOPLE WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT. THIS IS
NOT OKAY THIS ENTIRE PROCESS IS
SHAMEFUL CAN WE THE PEOPLE NOT
HI THE GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU.
NEED MORE ROOM FOR LOBBYIST IN
YOUR BUILDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
TIMOTHY HOLIDAY I'M SORRY MY
NAME IS TIMOTHY HOLIDAY I'M A
CONCERNED CITIZEN. AND I'VE
COME TO THE CAPITOL TODAY- AS A
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO- I'M VERY
TROUBLED BY YOUR PLANS TO
DEMOLISH AND REPLACE. AN
HISTORIC PUBLIC MONUMENT AT THE
TIME OF VERY SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
AUSTERITY IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES. WITH THE ECONOMY
BARELY RECOVERING PLEASE SET AN
EXAMPLE OF RESPONSIBILITY AND
NOT HUBRIS. PLEASE IT RENOVATE
WITHIN THE FOOTPRINT OF THIS
GREAT HISTORIC STRUCTURE. AND
PRESERVE ITS SURROUNDING PARK
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. YES
OKAY. I KNOW THIS CAN BUSINESS
INFORMATION WE'RE- SECURITY
CENTER- OF. ARM I WANT TO THANK
ALL FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND OF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION HEARING AND- THIS
HEARING OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE IS HEREBY ADJOURNED.